[Music]
your days of fighting for the so-called
greater good
are over
this is our chance
to control the truth the concepts
of right and wrong
for everyone for centuries to come
you're fighting to save an ideal that
doesn't exist
never did
you need to pick a side
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
kids get to popcorn now let me tell you
the story of the space viking thor
odinson
he was no ordinary man he was a god
after saving planet earth for the 500th
time thor set off on a new journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead bod
to god bod
and after all that
he reclaimed his title
as the one and only four
oh spook too soon
jane
[Music]
the old ex-girlfriend
what's your family three four years
eight years seven months and six days
give or take
am i um sensing feelings
[Music]
well you're right
the only ones who gods care about
is themselves
so this is my vow
all gods will die
i just want to say that was very very
impressive what you did back there
[Music]
it's just my first bad guy
[Music]
you never forget your first
you
are not like the only gods that kill
because i have something worth fighting
for
[Music]
let's see who you are i take off your
disguise
and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
should we help him eventually great
[Music]
hey look out the window
welcome to my party guys
[Music]
thank you so much for having us this is
my chance to reconnect with the girls
did mom shoot someone's face this little
bump right here that's you i still miss
her every day
[Music]
i've never seen anything like this
multiple attacks
without eating a spray
pliers don't do that
at least no lion i've ever seen
go back to the calls
breathe slow down
we're in his territory now
it's the law of the jungle
it's the only law that matters
i need you to trust me right now
i'm coming back
don't you move
he
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
you ain't never land in that plane
you ain't [ __ ]
you shouldn't even be flying
it's good to know the men you're flying
with
[Music]
see what they're fighting for
what are you fighting for
hoping to find that out
[Music]
try to keep up
[Music]
[Music]
people have told me to give up quit
die even
that's why you can't always do what
you're told
if i did
i wouldn't be here
[Music]
[Applause]
our country itself is sick
but it's lost its sense of direction
even its common decency you don't so
much as wiggles fingers
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a lot of people saying a lot of
things
but in the end you got to listen to
yourself
in that moment elvis the man was
sacrificed and elvis the god was born
you're looking for trouble
you came
[Applause]
[Music]
he had no idea what he had done
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
will be talking about
[Music]
we don't do the business the business
will do you i'm gonna do what i want to
do let's play the music that i want
[Music]
is god-given
so there can't be nothing wrong with it
if you don't listen to me
now that your mama i sacrificed for you
would be for nothing
trust
got a lot of talk about the new elvis
[Applause]
most people ain't gonna chase me none
i think if you dream he'll do it
i've never met anyone like you
i hope not
[Music]
without me there would be no elvis
presley
whatever once told me
that things are too dangerous to say
[Music]
sing
ladies and gentlemen here's elvis
presley
[Music]
this ain't no nostalgia show
we're gonna do something different
in town they tell the story of the marsh
girl
the one who grew up alone in the wild
but they never really knew me
like most stories
the facts don't weigh into it
i didn't know how to do life you didn't
see me
i was better off learning from the marsh
miss kyle i hear not my muscles
the marsh taught me how to survive
but it couldn't teach me everything
you can't live alone in the marsh
forever
watch me all right
it's dangerous to live out here alone
like this
i'm fine here's something else ain't you
miss katherine clark is charged with the
murder
of chase andrews
prosecution has announced it will seek
the death penalty
i'm going to get out of here
one way or the other
be careful y'all know some out there i
will not live in fear
there were no footprints fingerprints
nothing
someone destroyed evidence
i know you have a world of reasons to
hate these people i never hated them
they hated me
you want me to beg for my life
i won't
[Music]
it's a dangerous world in it i don't
know if there is a dark side to nature
just inventive ways to endure
against all odds
[Music]
it's 400 miles to asthma
long way to go for a party
they said david we're lost that's the
time what's that no david
it was an accident
stepped out in front of us you don't
want the police showing up
poking their noses into everything
you got into a car with a drunk which
makes you an accessory like i've been in
accessory for a long time now
listen are you going to mobile weekend
why are you going to enjoy yourself it's
another time you enjoy yourself you know
i suppose i can make the opera
did he mention money no
he wants you to return with them to bury
the boy it is parts
people disappear here they just vanished
[Music]
[Music]
they run over him
maybe more than once
what do they call it in a country
roadkill
there's nowhere to run nowhere to hide
has it occurred to you that he might
actually be planning something a lot
nastier than anything you can anticipate
you've forgotten about my husband
yes i have i'm sorry
why did you come here
i have a story
okay
i'm in west texas where this family just
lost their daughter to an opiate
overdose oh my god i'm so sorry it's
okay it's not something i was close to
but you flew to texas for it uh
yes uh it was a girl i hooked up with a
few times her family thought that we
were more serious than i did i've heard
so much about you i've i've heard
yeah
evelyn just didn't die she was murdered
what
the two of us are going to adventure
dead
so as like a personal boundary i don't
avenge deaths but here's what i can do
i'm gonna record everything that you
think happened to abilene and we'll put
it on a podcast and we'll see where it
leads what evidence does he have that it
was a murder
nothing and that's the story
what's this podcast about a new american
reality where people invent these
conspiracies you got deep state pill
pushers cartels the law because the
truth is too hard to accept
my prius exploded oh my god what if
you're driving a real car with gas and
stuff
the problem isn't that these people
aren't smart the problem is that they
are how do you take them coffee
in the mouth
if you want people to open up to you you
got to act like one of us
who here is a diehard fan of the
university of texas
[Applause]
and who here is a fan of texas
what if she was murdered this just keeps
getting bigger and bigger looks like two
pairs of prints cowboy boots calling out
an apb to find two men wearing cowboy
boots
what happened to her why do you care so
much why do you care so little
you're so lucky in you emily i really
don't know what you saw me hurt caesar
texas
you can't solve something like this with
a 45. it's the breakdown of society's
what it is it's just women i think
that's very nice you're going to need a
12-gauge couple of ars no western
automatic and a sidearm for safety
where are you right now uh i'm in an
uber
questions have arisen such as who is he
what is he where did he come from is he
a creature of a foreign power is he a
creep is he dangerous is he smart dumb
nice to his parents real put on crazy
sane man woman robot what is this
are you there david
are you there mr david bowie
all people no matter who they are
all wish they'd appreciated life more
it's what you do in life that's
important
not how much time you have
[Music]
or what you wish you'd done
[Applause]
[Music]
life is fantastic
[Music]
[Music]
i'm leo you must be nancy may i come
inside yes
so i've made a list of things that i'd
like to get through number one i perform
oral sex on you number two you perform
oral sex on me number three we do a 69
if that's what it's still called um four
me on top five doggy style
that all sounds very achievable i booked
enough time
you you want to do it all today
yes no
i've never had an orgasm there are nuns
out there with more sexual experience
than me it's embarrassing don't want me
to brush my teeth
oh god this is crazy it's terrible it's
wrong nancy yes come have a dance at me
hi
[Music]
i guess i'm frustrated cleo grande your
real name thinking about all the places
i should have been by now i simply don't
understand why you're doing this it's
disabled for our college oh how
wonderful are you really no
i've always been ashamed of my body your
body's beautiful i wish you could see
that
everyone wants something different i
don't judge my clients unless they're
top rehearsals
i've never done anything interesting in
my life
[Music]
you're the only adventure i've ever had
what's the oldest person you've ever
done it with 82 82 yes 82. nancy okay
i'm feeling a bit better now
[Music]
hi everyone it's bobby lieber and
welcome to your favorite podcast where i
talk about whatever i feel like talking
about
so these big movie producers came to me
and said we want you to write a rom-com
about a gay couple
something a straight guy might even like
and watch with his girlfriend gay guys
are my jam awesome something a straight
guy might like am i going to be in the
middle of some high speed chase then all
of a sudden fall in love with ice cube
am i going to get [ __ ] by jason
mamoa while we're both worrying about a
volcano they said we just want a movie
that shows the world that gay
relationships and straight relationships
are the same love is love is love i said
love is love is love no it's not that is
[ __ ]
our friendships are different i have to
go to a party and you're too old to be
in the pool
please leave our sex lives are different
aspect don't have ass pic must-see pick
of ass
took this just for you bro
did he block me our relationships are
different this is bisexual awareness
week and no one has acknowledged it
lesbian history month was in march
nobody said a goddamn thing of course
lesbians get a month and we get a week i
don't want any hollywood [ __ ] no
scenes where two guys are about to hook
up and all of a sudden the camera
conveniently pulls away
oh
hey i'm gonna go this is nice meeting
you yeah youtube is lovely
[Music]
my whole life i prided myself on being
self-reliant
what is going on with you this
[ __ ] has gone into my head
are you into one of these [ __ ] ripped
idiots with no opinions no i'd like
someone who's physically very frail and
won't stop talking
maybe you're both bottomed and that's
the problem
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god gay sex was more fun when
straight people were uncomfortable with
it
anyway it doesn't matter i'm not the
right person to write a rom-com anyway
[Music]
oh my god do you guys remember straight
people yeah they had a nice run
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
live from the
middle of the [ __ ] woods
working on this new album right quick
man
you know new [ __ ] going down
yeah
uh
right by and i thought gang sign uh big
bomb what up play boy how you doing good
to see you
it's a little different
it's good to get some fresh air you know
kind of hit mute on everything i just
don't want you sinking into the mental
space you were in before i set you up
you know
my grandfather used to have farmland i'd
be lying to you if i said i wasn't
interested in it a little bit so you
know me helping you was like
helping me i'm heading them toward you
just stay wide let's go let's go let's
get it let's get it
here's the bottom you got some flow man
i see you rocking that [ __ ] a little bit
what's the secret
check yourself
big bob never wrecked yourself
me and bob we be too in the blow
me and bob will be torn
[Music]
this new york show coming up man it's
getting more and more crazy by the day
black's on the wall ain't no stop
selling dope yeah
i don't know i don't know if i'm ready
to jump back on stage yet man you kind
of got the bricky by the center on the
boat jeff you gonna lose everything you
got to focus you have a goal here bro
yeah back to the trap with a
[ __ ] pack yeah these [ __ ]
know the lingo
you love what you do i mean what other
job in music do you got to worry about
getting shot
[Music]
you crazy what you doing here
why you really want to stay around here
want that feeling bad
family camp is the highlight of our year
you asked our family it's the greatest
place on earth i'm sorry i was late
again
what do i got to do to make it up to you
how about we go to that camp
church camp
[Applause]
hey family welcome to camp for the
ackermann's don't seem to have an
acronym here on the list you made the
final payment online right
alright
goodness oh my goodness
you guys this is clamping
no wi-fi i can't wait until you realize
there's no air conditioning what now
where is my yummy bride oh
honey hi hello your family oh i'm great
stop not another word
oh
oh
here's my card intergalactic
chiropractic
oh buckle up everybody
the camp could talk with trophy you
should see this baby on my mantel at
home the family takes on the most points
up in the week takes the cup
from my cold dead hands if you think
we're gonna be friends with that guy you
need your head examined we're not
monsters okay even though we do make
sugar-free organic vegan non-dairy
marshmallows
today we are gonna do the buddy system
let's go bucko i should have known
better than to trust you you have no
idea where we are come on
this is our story to tell our wives how
we braved the wilderness on our way back
home get that thing away from me my skin
is on fire
sounds like that kind of party
we have a problem our husbands are out
there on their own and we don't even
know where they are i'm stuck here with
dr phil's demented twin brother when i
should be back at the camp singing in
kumbaya with my family it's okay me
amigo when god closes the door he opens
a chick-fil-a goes like this
i thought my family would just magically
become the family that i've always
wanted them to be things get a little
more complicated when you get a peek
behind the curtain
that was fun that was something you're
welcome
all right
[Music]
your dad passed yesterday how'd he die
lung cancer
nice
your dad left everything to you all of
the apartments are in your name
what apartments your pops you said you
would be like this haven't seen them in
10 years did they tell you that
go introduce yourself to all the tenants
i don't speak english you just spoke
english i never spoke english in my life
my name is lucas and i'm just going
around the apartment introducing myself
to everybody look at the bugs
do you know how to do that i mean you
know manage an apartment
[Music]
qualifications you know like for the
build like to run buildings
like no i don't
why are you here lucas you said you
wanted to sell right
but i also
don't want to go back to reno
bet you haven't gone through your
father's stuff yet huh it's okay to be
angry it's not it's not [ __ ] okay
it's not okay that he did that
it's weird i feel like everybody knew
him except me maybe it was his way to
show you he loved you yeah i don't know
about that but just too bad you'll never
get to know him like that i'm not happy
here man you're not happy anyway lucas
no matter where you are because it's in
here and it's in here well that's your
friend with the dead dad yeah what's his
name again
sometimes you just try to like
take a step back
being an adult sucks
most people think that a man is supposed
to keep everything bottled up inside but
really it's much harder to open up
[Music]
i wish
things were different
but
i just want you to know
that i
are you not from vegas
no i'm from reno oh
well
why aren't you from vegas reno sucks
i've got 10 minutes catch me up we are
officially on breakup numero 9.
well let's hope it sticks this time
niko's like one of those dementors they
suck the soul out of people through
their faces
maybe i'm making too big a deal out of
this whole monogamous thing it's really
hard to just let him go
the hamster wheel of your addiction to
nico has to be destroyed we would like
to meet someone say hello to your new
fake boyfriend what christianity you are
now in a relationship across all social
media wait what that's the plan baby
yeah
it's getting real
homie i saw the new man on insta good
for you
so explain yourself
nico was so angry
and i finally know what it's like to
have a little bit of power
i own that man
do you want me to text that back for you
jesus christ troy stay out of my
business
hi welcome
there's a guy he is a chef
you're andrew right so you're finally
the class you wouldn't know how bad of a
cook i am actually trying to make
breakfast one time and then we ended up
at virginia
that was you yeah
you better do cristiano i don't need him
anymore we can't delete cristiano just
yet
singapore oh okay
please no clapping i'm only a man
i gotta show raffy the real me cristiano
just hit 1.6 million followers do you
think that this might be getting a
little out of hand there's something not
right here
ah the longer this goes on the worse it
gets i can't just delete him jake he's
not real he's real to me
i'm sure andrew's told you all about
this new boyfriend
he's a philanthropist and renowned human
rights activist he still finds time to
make sweet love to little andrew for
hours on end uh wow
sounds too good to be true it is
[Applause]
they're all dead
these aerosols this fog is toxic
commander that not your ground
can anybody hear me
[Music]
if anyone else is out there please
answer
[Music]
how long can we stay up here growing old
here never seeing earth what kind of a
light is that we are a group
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it could blow up any seconds
[Music]
there's no shame in caring for your own
life hannah
my name's brian
this is my infamous inventions pantry
it's actually a cow shed
things went a bit topsy-turvy in my life
i was very alone
ah fiddlesticks that's when i just
started making stuff
any little idea i had i just made it's
an egg belt pine cone bag flying cougar
clock though whenever anyone in the
village wants to know the time they can
look up in the air and i'll be there
they don't always work and the stuff i
build isn't for everyone i'm impressed
thanks
my new projects i'm building a robot
didn't look too bad does he i wonder
what he'll do when i turn him on
would you like me to give you a name
tony
charles
charles
charles charles you like that name do
you hello brian hello charles it's
lovely to meet you
this is incredibly overwhelming imagine
me and you i do
i never thought i'd make anything as
amazing as charles you built my body
and my tummy is a washing machine and
his tummy is a washing machine so happy
together
she's showing
imagine i want to go on an adventure
everything is lovely
it's not all lovely
i want to sit in the front ryan no
you're not sitting in the front
[Music]
i'm not a child i can look after myself
man what's going to you
i tend to learn from each thing and i
build
[ __ ]
i am your friend run i'm your friend
i want to go to honolulu charles what
are you wearing it's my hawaiian hula
skirt
[Applause]
when you have kids
yeah
it changes everything
before
it was all about
you right
worrying about
stupid crap
like you're the center of your own
little universe
trouble is
all that
goes away in the blink of an eye
i don't know where lollies
my daughter's missing it's not your
mom's fault she didn't come home from
school i needed help me was your
daughter's name
laurie
she went missing six years ago
[Music]
um
comes to 122 pounds 50.
you know how much is in there thirty
years for me
what are you going to spend it on mum
we need it now
police in brighton are asking for
witnesses
after a 12 year old girl was snatched
from outside of her school at 3 30
yesterday
there's been a development in the zoe
davie case i was just wondering if you
had the chance to see if the same thing
happened to my lolly
[Music]
sit down
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you